We are so excited to have one of the most iconic pop stars
of all time at this desk.
She just released her first original album in 20 years
called "The Body Remembers."
Please welcome the one, the only,
and our friend of the show, Debbie Gibson.
(audience cheering)
Yes, Debbie Gibson!
Hi, my friend.
I love so much.
Hi.
I love you more than words can say.
And, Debbie, really.
Aw, mutual.
I just thank you 'cause you came on the show really early.
Oh my gosh.
And we talked on Zoom.
You were at your house,
you were taking out the trash.
In my Envys.
Yes, exactly.
Doing your whole life as a musical.
Yes.
Now can I ask why
you named this "The Body Remembers"?
What a great title.
Thank you.
So I heard a great word recently, newstalgic,
and it feels like everybody craves, nostalgia.
Like we all wanna live in a modern world,
we all wanna be who we are now,
but we want all the good feels
from those times that we remember, that our body remembers.
Those first concerts.
Oh yeah.
That first kiss.
We also remember the traumatic stuff.
And I'm someone who loves
to disguise layered messages
in hooky dance songs.
So it's like you can be enjoying it, "Hey."
And then you're like, "Wait a minute,
I think I just got something richer from the lyric."
And so that's what this album is.
And Joey McIntyre is on the album also.
We remade "Lost in Your Eyes" as a duet.
I love that.
(audience cheering)
Right?
Debbie, and I hear you have some breaking news.
So there's a couple of things.
First of all, I'm going on tour this summer.
Yeah!
Yeah, where, when can we go see?
Can we come, can we come?
I'm on the East Coast, I'm in Jersey, I'm on Long Island,
so I'll send you guys a car.
Oh, we're coming.
Okay.
But then there was something else,
I'm working on a holiday album this year too.
(Ross and Drew gasping)
Debbie does Christmas?
Yeah!
Oh my god, I'm changing the title to that.
That could be a really fun title.
That is hysterical.
But what I wanted to share with you also,
'cause I was talking about Joey
is he and I are dueting again.
We co-wrote an original, Joey McIntyre and I,
for the holiday album as well.
And my dad, who's also a Joe, my two favorite Joes,
he and I sing "White Christmas" together.
Oh my god.
Oh, come on.
You and Christmas,
I can't handle it.
I can't wait.
So bring it on.
We like to deliver news, pop culture information here.
So will you hit some headlines with us?
Yes, to me.
Come on, Debbie.
Right, all right, Debbie, kick us off!
Okay.
(audience cheering)
First, we've got some exciting news about in-flight dining,
oh, I love a good in-flight meal, on today's Food News.
(audience cheering)
So VegNews reports,
Delta is doing plant-based meals for the first time.
And here's what's on the menu,
an Impossible Burger topped with manchego on a brioche bun,
pan-fried cauliflower cakes with creamy pesto orzo,
that sounds amazing,
and meatless lamb meatballs with spinach rice and feta.
Delta says the choice is not
just because plant-based meals are delicious,
but also because they're more sustainable.
Many of these meatless options
use less land and water than meat.
I love this.
You do?
I do.
(audience cheering)
Me too.
As a frequent flyer,
I don't really want meat up in the sky.
I don't why, I don't want the fish, I don't want the meat.
I always forget to order the vegetarian meal.
I travel all the time.
I would love, like I'm so into this.
May Delta be the first of many airlines to do this, why not?
Why not?
All right, next up we've got, this is fun,
we have an '80s makeup style
that TikTok says will be everywhere in 2022.
The List reports, something called blush draping
is all the rage.
I didn't know what it was,
but it's applying rosy blush with a real heavy hand
and extending it all the way up to your temples.
Okay, now you are two great beauties.
Is this something you do?
I mean I don't,
but I'll try it.
You'll try it?
Well, we have some Flower Beauty right here.
Okay, I know I have some,
you sent me some Flower Beauty
many moons ago and I love it.
I love sending you Flower Beauty, Debbie.
Ooh.
How's that?
Coming in with you, Debbie.
Look, that went on thicker than I thought it was going to.
That's a little.
Oh, sorry.
Let's see, Rossy.
Oh, I love it.
Do you?
I love it!
Then screw it.
I'll do this side too, okay.
(audience cheering)
Ooh, I was a little heavy handed, that's okay.
It's really like groovy.
You know, they say '80s, but it feels more '70s, right?
You know what's amazing?
Is like I feel like all of a sudden
I have more oomph.
I have more color, I have more like, you know.
No, Rossy, I mean.
You look like a Holly Hobbie Doll or something.
I feel like I'm on the cover
of your Christmas album, you know what I mean?
Like brr, it's cold out here, Debbie.
By the way, you are looking
very Christmas elfie.
Totally.
I'll do my nose a little bit.
Very like toy soldier.
Oh, brr.
Oh my god.
You know what?
That's the crazy thing, like color changes everything.
I feel like I went from a little sullen
to like really poppy.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It looks great on you though.
'Cause you've got like a groovy vibe anyway.
You can kind of rock anything.
Listen, if you put on, put that foot up again, Debbie,
put that foot up.
You throw on that and a red lip.
Yeah, you're set.
And your entire energy is gonna change.
Just a little bit of footwear and a bright lip.
I swear to you.
May I blend?
Yeah, get in here.
You will literally.
See this is a real friend, right?
Thank you, Debbie.
Now you've got like that lovely,
just winter little chill.
Okay, did she fix me?
Debbie, you're right.
Is that better?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
You look better, yeah.
Hi, okay, now I'm beautiful.
Thank you.
All right, this story
I had to sneak in, because I just loved it so much.
Breaking news, you guys.
Brady is back!
Why, no, wow!
You guys, it didn't last.
People reports that after retired for one month,
Brady has announced he's coming back as quarterback
for the Tampa Bay Buccaneers.
This will be his 23rd season.
Five-time Super Bowl MVP says
he's just got unfinished business on that field.
And my favorite quote comes
from Stephen Colbert's response on Twitter.
He says, "Tom Brady got one taste of what it's like
to help kids with math homework
and decided to return to being tackled
by the largest men in the world."
Oh, every mother can relate.
Welcome back, Tom Brady!
We sort of missed you?
Glad you're back.
(upbeat music)